monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les différents vaccins contre le sarkopf
2 actuellement disponible sur le marché
bénéficie d'une autorisation de mise sur
le marché conditionnel dont la durée
n'excède pas un an les essais cliniques
de phase 3 sont toujours en cours
consacrant un caractère expérimental de
cette vaccination inédite dans
l'histoire pour rappel selon le site de
l'anémie sm une AMM conditionnelle
permet je cite l'autorisation de
médicaments qui répondent à un besoin
médical non satisfait avant que des
données à long terme sur l'efficacité la
sécurité ne soit disponible cela est
possible uniquement si des bénéfices de
la disponibilité immédiate du médicament
l'emporte sur les risques inhérents au
fait que toutes les données ne sont pas
encore disponibles la MM conditionnel
rassemble tous les verrous de contrôle
d'une autorisation de mission le marché
standard pour garantir un niveau élevé
de sécurité pour les patients fin de
citation rendre obligatoire
l'administration des vaccins génétiques
dont la phase expérimentale est toujours
en cours est ainsi politiquement
imprudente et moralement condamnable
c'est même impossible juridiquement dans
l'état actuel de la réglementation pour
des raisons parfaitement fondées liées à
la préservation de la santé publique et
au libre consentement de chacun cette
proposition de loi contrevient en effet
à toutes les règles internationales en
matière de santé publique la convention
de viedo de 97 signé par 29 pays dont la
France qui disposent qu'une intervention
dans le domaine de la santé ne peut être
effectuée qu'après que la personne
concernée y a donné son consentement
libre et éclairé cette personne reçoit
préalablement une information adéquate
quant au but et à la nature de
l'intervention ainsi qu'à ses
conséquences et ses risques la personne
concernée peut à tout moment librement
retirer son consentement l'assemblée du
Conseil de l'Europe dans sa résolution
du 27 janvier 2021 demande instamment
aux États membres de l'Union européenne
en son article 7 3 1 je cite de
s'assurer que les citoyennes et citoyens
sont informés que la vaccination n'est
pas obligatoire et que les personnes ne
subit de pression politique social ou
autre pour se faire vacciner je suis
obligé de vous interrompre
quelle est la vie de la Commission
oui
madame la Présidente
la vie de la Commission sur cette
amendement et défavorable nous venons
d'avoir un débat très intéressant
sur l'obligation vaccinale et votre
amendement n'est pas un amendement
d'opposition à l'obligation vaccinale ça
vous aurez l'occasion de repousser la
proposition de loi c'est un amendement
d'opposition au vaccin et votre exposé
des motifs reprend un certain nombre
d'arguments qui sont régulièrement
imposées proposés par ceux qui sont
opposés à la vaccination et je voudrais
juste en citer quelques-uns d'abord vous
invoquez le caractère expérimental de
cette vaccination nous ne sommes pas
dans une expérimentation ces vaccins
sont titulaires d'une autorisation de
mise sur le marché et une autorisation
de mise sur le marché ne veut pas dire
qu'il en est terminé de la surveillance
et des processus de pharmacovigilance
vis-à-vis d'un produit qui est sur le
marché mais veut dire que le produit a
satisfait à tout un ensemble de règles
aux trois premières phases et que il est
susceptible d'être distribué normalement
et c'est ce qui se passe et le nombre de
vaccinations qui a été effectué depuis
que les vaccins ont obtenus la MM
témoignent de leur parfait profil des
faits secondaires
d'ailleurs la FD a maintenant on va dire
terminer
entièrement la procédure et je cite la
vie de la FDA qui est que le public peut
être assuré que le vaccin répond aux
normes élevées de sécurité d'efficacité
et de qualité de production dont la FDA
exige le respect pour un produit
autorisé aux États-Unis c'est plus de
230 millions de doses qui ont été
délivrées ce ne sont pas monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est maintenant au
gouvernement
merci ma Président
je rappelle au collègue que le Sénat
dans sa grande sagesse a décidé de
ramener à deux minutes le temps
d'intervention et voilà donc nous
appliquons les deux minutes
monsieur le ministre est-ce que ça vous
est-ce que ça s'applique à vous et bien
non malheureusement la constitution de
l'interdit malheureusement madame la
Présidente merci
mesdames et mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les les sénateurs
vous l'avez compris dans mon dans ma
déclaration générale nous nous opposons
à l'instauration d'une obligation et
pour autant madame la sénatrice
nous réfutons avec force un certain
nombre d'arguments que vous avez que
vous avez développé vous évoquez
effectivement les AMM conditionnels et
je ne peux pas laisser passer
dans cette assemblée le sous-entendu sur
le caractère expérimental et non contre
les de ses vaccins ce sont depuis le
début de la vaccination plus de 7
milliards
d'injections qui ont été réalisées dans
le monde cela fait quasiment un an
désormais de recul que nous avons à
partir des premières injections vous ne
pouvez pas parler raisonnablement de
caractères expérimental et non contrôlée
de ces vaccins vous citez des éléments
d'information délivrés par la NSM qui
rappelle que les vaccins contre la
covid-19 ont été autorisés avec tous les
éléments de contrôle garantissant leur
sécurité c'est le cas je vais être un
peu long madame la Présidente je m'en
excuse mais il me paraît indispensable
de vous rappeler que d'une part la
décision d'autoriser ou non un vaccin ne
relève pas du gouvernement mais
appartient bien aux autorités
scientifiques indépendantes qui sont en
charge de l'évaluation des produits de
santé que concernant les vaccins contre
la covid-19 c'est l'agent européenne des
médicaments qui est chargé de leur
évaluation s'appuyant sur l'expertise
des 27 agences sanitaires dont la NSM
pour la France et en France je rappelle
également que la vie de la Haute
Autorité de Santé nécessaire pour
préciser la place de chaque vaccin dans
la stratégie vaccinale et notamment les
populations aussi voilà ces différents
constitue des garanties indispensables
avant de commencer avec Disney en France
ils ont tous été respectés
vous dites que nous sommes encore une
forme de conditionnalité dans les textes
où il peut être mais dans la réalité je
vous ai donné les chiffres
ce n'est pas le cas plus de 7 milliards
d'injections près d'un an désormais de
politique vaccinale déployées dans le
monde par ailleurs tous les vaccins qui
ont été commercialisés dans l'Union
européenne sont soumis à un double
contrôle de la qualité des doses
fabriqués se contrôler effectuant
parallèle par le fabricant et par
laboratoire de contrôle officiel dont
vous savez qu'il est indépendant et
enfin s'agissant des vaccins contre la
covid-19 la NSM a mis en place un double
dispositif renforcé de pharmacovigilance
et de pharmaco
épidémoniologie afin d'assurer le suivi
et la gestion des effets indésirables
qui serait lié donc une fois encore nous
nous opposons à l'obligation vaccinale
généralisée vous l'avez compris mais
parce que nous croyons à l'incitation à
l'information à la pédagogie en
direction de nos concitoyens et je crois
que les dernières semaines les derniers
mois viennent à démontrer que cette
stratégie est la bonne mais en aucun cas
pour les arguments que vous avancez dans
votre dans votre amendement raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement
sur la base des arguments que vous avez
développé et met un avis défavorable à
cet amende
avant de donner la parole à la
présidente de roche je voudrais rappeler
à nos collègues que si c'est amendement
était adopté il interromperait la
discussion et ferait tomber l'article
unique de la proposition de loi madame
la Présidente vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente pour bien
expliquer qu'elle a été la position de
la Commission nous avons voté contre
l'article unique de cette proposition de
loi ça a été dit d'ailleurs par à la
milong quand il a parlé au nom du groupe
donc nous aurions pu dire on va voter
l'amendement puisqu'en effet il supprime
l'article premier ce qui aura le même
résultat simplement au regard des des
motifs exposés dans l'objet il n'a
semblait pas possible à la Commission de
soutenir cet amendement au regard des
arguments développés le ministre les a
dit Bernard je mets l'a dit des
collègues le diront on ne peut accepter
cet amendement par rapport à des
explications qui sont celles des antivax
qui nous ont sollicités tout au long de
ces semaines donc dans ces conditions la
commission un avis défavorable à
l'amendement mais en revanche elle
donnera un avis favorable à la
suppression de l'article premier et donc
un avis contre l'adoption de l'article
premier et l'article unique de cette
proposition
merci la parole est à Madame Corinne
Ferret
pardon sur une explication vous avez la
parole madame Ferret pour deux minutes
merci outil de l'explication de votre
sur cet amendement je m'étais je
regrette véritablement de retrouver dans
l'argumentaire de des parlementaires
signataires la notion de vaccins
génétique qui était erronée qui véhicule
des peurs infondées la technique de la
RN messager suscite de nombreuses
questions du fait de sa nouveauté c'est
légitime mais plutôt que de reprendre
les fantasmes véhiculés par certains via
les réseaux sociaux je préfère moi mon
référé à l'INSERM l'étude de l'inseum
pour rétablir les vérités scientifiques
je veux aussi
dire un mot sur les derniers mots que
vous n'avez pas à prononcer madame
mais qui figure dans l'argumentaire de
votre amendement au nom de la liberté
individuelle en matière de santé
au nom de la liberté individuelle en
matière de santé mais quand la liberté
individuelle porte une atteinte à la
santé collective de la population alors
l'équilibre doit être rétabli par la loi
afin de protéger l'ensemble de la
société et c'est aujourd'hui pour nous
une question de solidarité nationale la
vaccination est un devoir citoyen qui
incombe à chacun pour se protéger et
protéger les autres vous l'avez compris
nous votre compte
merci la parole est à Monsieur Milon
oui merci madame la Présidente je salue
après l'intervention qui vient d'être
faite par Madame Noël le calme de
Bernard jaumier du ministre et de
Catherine de roche je dois dire qu'à
leur place j'aurais certainement fait
des bons puisque je trouve les propos
qui ont été exprimés en petits vaccin
complètement inadmissible je dois dire
que aujourd'hui j'ai honte
[Musique]
la parole d'un monsieur Savary
oui merci madame la Présidente
moi je suis revu c'est parce que c'est
un débat qui mérite d'être posé
on oublie trop facilement qu'il y a eu
des morts et des morts moi je suis
étonné quand même j'habite dans le Grand
Est
épidémie elle est venue c'est une porte
d'entrée c'est l'Alsace l'épidémie quand
même il y a eu ne l'oublions pas en
France plus de morts que dans d'autres
Paris comparé à la population
qui nous habite en conséquence faut pas
faut beaucoup d'humilité dans l'approche
de tout cela et on n'a pas le droit me
semble-t-il de ne pas donner confiance à
notre population à travers les vaccins
qui sont une révolution extraordinaire
quand on n'avait pas de vaccin on
pleurait tous on pleurait tous qu'on
n'avait pas de vaccin maintenant qu'on
les qu'on a les vaccins faut plus
vacciner il y a quand même quelque chose
qui va pas on a un coup des tests qui
est tellement plus supérieur au vaccin
donc la question de la vaccination ne se
pose pas par contre la question de l'O
vaccinale se pose c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas éliminer faut pas éliminer
cette arme suprême qui peut être
importante monsieur le ministre vous
dites c'est une applicable mais vous
aviez déjà dit à l'époque qu'on pouvait
pas utiliser les moyens numériques qu'il
fallait pas de pas de sanitaire puis
finalement la gravité de l'épidémie a
montré que il fallait se tourner vers
cela j'espère qu'on aura pas ce tourner
vers l'obligation vaccinale mais en tout
cas c'est tout à fait légitime de se
poser la question de cette obligation
mais sûrement pas de l'intérêt du vaccin
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre
c'est un beau débat et c'est un débat
passionnel il suffit de voir le nombre
de mains qui se lèvent pour s'exprimer
beaucoup de choses ont été dites et je
ne prendrai pas 2 minutes moi je ne vais
pas voter l'obligation vaccinale parce
que je crois qu'elle est
contre-productive mais en revanche par
rapport au vaccin j'affirme
tranquillement que j'ai une admiration
sans borne pour Louis Pasteur j'aime la
science et je pense qu'en tant que élu
et parlementaire nous avons un devoir de
confiance un devoir de rassurer les
populations de convaincre celles et ceux
qui peuvent légitimement être réticents
et donc je ne voterai pas cette
amendement parce que dans l'exposé des
motifs il avance des choses qui génèrent
de de la méfiance et qui au fond risque
de renforcer les les doutes ou les
propos des anti vaccins la raison pour
laquelle je ne voterai pas cette
amendement mais je ne voterai pas non
plus l'obligation vaccinale je vous
remercie merci Monsieur Hervé
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues moi j'ai
signé cet amendement de Sylviane de Noël
d'abord parce qu'il supprime parce qu'il
supprime
l'essentiel de cette proposition de loi
à laquelle je m'oppose fermement comme
j'avais pu mes m'opposer comme l'oppose
depuis le mois de décembre au
déploiement du Pass sanitaire dans notre
pays parce que je alors voyons
parce que quand j'entends notre collègue
ça varie qui a consigné avec Madame
Guillotin et Madame l'avare un rapport
qui peut faire aussi l'objet d'un débat
si on interdit à Madame Noël de parler
dans cette émission dit je ne peux pas
laisser de passer tel ou tel chose alors
à ce moment-là la démocratie n'a plus
aucun sens aucun sens et on a le droit
ici au Parlement et son j'ai bien son
génie quand même que le texte qui arrive
derrière
allez-y qui a été présenté ce matin au
Conseil des Ministres est un texte qui
aura pour objet qui n'y est pas de débat
parlementaire avant fin juillet 2022
donc mes chers collègues si on veut que
le débat parlementaire ait lieu laissez
madame Noël défendent ces arguments je
vais partager pas tous mais laissez-la
des ventes arguments venez avec des
contrats arguments mais
de grâce ne venez jamais avec des avec
des des arguments qui touchent
simplement au fait de disqualifier
l'argument individuel pour convaincre
c'est valable pour la vaccination c'est
valable pour l'équilibre entre la
liberté et la coercition il faut
toujours mieux convaincre que empêcher
son adversaire de parler
[Musique]